martinica se despertó con la
intervención de la policía y de los
bomberos en los bloqueos que todavía
cortan muchas frutas del territorio
francés la visita del ministro de
ultramar no calmó las tensiones que
sacuden a la isla desde hace nueve días
sin embargo antes de regresar a parís
sebastián con él declaró que no cerraba
la puerta a una adaptación de la
obligación de vacunación para el
personal sanitario y los bomberos
en el tema de salud en el tema de la
vacunación obligatoria como he dicho se
aplica la ley de la república sin
embargo la cuestión de cómo aplicar esta
ley se basa en un principio de realidad
y lo digo con mucho sentido común hay un
principio de realidad en este territorio
y en materia social y sanitaria que se
impondrá a todos los partidos
un paso adelante destacado por los
sindicatos de martinica que
comprometieron a sentarse en la mesa de
negociaciones su meta es la continuidad
de la atención en el hospital y el
futuro del personal reciente a la
vacunación de diálisis bien somos y
somos realistas pero también entendemos
que la población tiene una porcentaje de
personas no vacunadas
y también sabemos que será difícil de
clasificar a 3000 personas porque de eso
se trata es familia son sedes aquí salió
si lo hace el diálogo está abierto
aunque los resultados de la visita del
ejecutivo en el caribe siguen siendo
dispares el lunes en guadalupe la isla
hermana se rompieron las discusiones
similares cuando los indicados se
negaron a condenar los ataques a la
policía este movimiento social sin
presidentes se ha extendido a
reivindicaciones políticas y sociales
especialmente contra el alto costo de la
vida en estos territorios franceses